Prince held annually in Las Vegas first
Thomas woods author of meltdown a free
market look at why the stock market
collapsed the economy tanked and
government bailouts will make things
worse this is 50 minutes
okay thank you ladies and gentlemen this
is the first conference I've ever been
to where there were eight other things
going on while i was speaking so i'm
glad to see there's anyone here
particularly since the other ones are
all involving how to hold onto your
wealth in these troubled times you guys
must know all about that nope at the the
high rollers here in the room thank you
for being with me I'd like to make a
little shout-out to my wife who is not
here but who is a wonderful woman who
together with me we're expecting in
addition to our family in the relatively
near future and we thankfully have a
wonderful relationship we're pretty much
the only thing we fight about is which
one of us is the better person and we're
each making the case for the other so
thanks to that I'm able to say to her
yeah honey I'm going by myself to a you
know conference in Las Vegas and I won't
be around for three days and that sort
of is ok you know that works that's all
right I'm thankful to a c-span for
creating this official historical record
that such an event did in fact occur Oh
what I'd like to talk about today of
course in very much revolves around the
subject of my book meltdown which I'm
happy to say spent ten weeks on the New
York Times bestseller list earlier this
year however the New York Times has
thank you thanks thank you very much new
york times though has refused to review
it however they'll still impose Paul
Krugman on us every week that we're not
going to be spared that every week we're
definitely going to get him but no no
dissent is allowed in the new york times
but on the other hand I think we all
know about the financial picture the New
York Times is facing so I I tend to
think it doesn't want to promote a book
that argues against bailouts given what
the media is obviously going to be
demanding in the near future well let's
not talk about that particular
depressing subject and in fact i don't i
hope i'm not going to depress you today
because i am going to leave you with the
suggestion that there is a way out of
this now whether or not they're going to
follow it is another question but it's
comforting to know that if we wanted to
get out of this economic mess we could
do it it's not impossible it can be done
now I'm not going to talk about some of
the things that you would likely
encounter if you turned on right wing
radio where you'd hear a lot of
denunciation of the Community
Reinvestment Act that introduced
affirmative action in lending or Fannie
Mae and Freddie Mac whose irresponsible
decisions where I think a fairly
significant factor in all this but all
the same there is nevertheless the
elephant in the living room the factor
that more than any other contributed to
the crisis but yet that never gets
mentioned is never mentioned in a
negative light in certainly in political
circles where in fact to the contrary
we're in effect encouraged not even to
think about it and that's the Federal
Reserve System now most Americans here
Federal Reserve System and they think I
don't even know what this is I'm never
going to know this is probably too
complicated and I better just let the
experts take care of this well that's
the problem the experts are a bunch of
quacks so it's important for us to learn
this material to know what's going on so
that we can have an informed opinion so
that we won't inadvertently enlist in
the army of drones who say that the
solution to the crisis is to give more
power to our wise overlords been there
done that the Federal Reserve System is
in effect in charge of the country's
money supply as I'm sure I don't need to
tell people in this room it has the
ability to increase or decrease it I
think we all know the direction it
normally goes it is supposed to act as a
lender of last resort for the financial
sector well there's one thing it knows
how to do right we've seen that that's
no problem I got that pretty well under
control and we're told that the Fed is a
great stabilizing agent in the economy
so really we shouldn't really be
questioning it because the Fed brings
scientific management to bear on our
money supply I mean who could question
that what kind of crank are you after
all you know this is this is for our own
good even the left which prides itself
on its slogan question authority falls
completely silent when it comes to the
Fed if you question the Fed well that's
taking question authority just a little
bit
too far well I intend to do that I think
those of us in this room are inclined
not just to accept whatever we're fed by
the establishment especially when the
establishment has been obviously so
wrong so we're inclined to ask
fundamental questions that are normally
passed over so for example normally what
happens when there's an economic crisis
of this kind is that we get people on
one side saying we need fiscal stimulus
we got to just blow a lot of borrowed
money on nonsense projects and that'll
make us rich and then the other side is
supposed to say oh no no let's just
print up a lot of money and spend it on
such-and-such and that's the big debate
that's the debate but yet we are
introducing into this debate a third
possibility which is that the first two
are completely juvenile and are only
going to make the situation worse now
what I'm going to be talking to you
about today though involves something
called the Austrian School of Economics
this has nothing to do with austria /
say other than a lot of the the early
figures in the school came from Austria
now this is important because right now
the Austrian school she's a school of
economic thought is the smallest
probably in the world it also happens to
be the oldest continuously existing
school of thought in the world and right
now it's the fastest growing why because
disproportionately economists of the
Austrian school predicted what we're
seeing at a time when the rest of the
profession was completely blindsided
James Galbraith estimates that maybe one
tenth or one one-hundredth of a percent
of professional economists saw this
crisis coming now naturally he's not
including the Austrian economists
because that's the job of James
Galbraith to pretend there are no
Austrian economists but we need to we
need to highlight these people because
they did see what's coming and that's
why people are interested in meanwhile
the mainstream so-called of the
economics profession has in my opinion
completely disgraced itself during this
crisis not only because it failed to see
it coming not only because they told us
this is the most robust economy anyone's
ever seen they said that in 2007 but
also because the solutions so-called
solutions they propose as I say are
utterly juvenile and extremely crude and
this is all they have to show for
themselves now the mainstream of the
economics profession has in effect
morphed from what was once a small
cultish corner of the profession namely
a group of people who thought that the
best thing for economics to do was to
ape physics so I think a lot of times in
economics we have former or would-be
physicists who for whatever reason
couldn't get through a physics program
and so the next best thing has become an
economist and try and ape the methods of
the physical sciences and so you come up
with absurd models that apply only to an
economy on Mars or that apply to an
economy and long-run equilibrium that
we're never going to reach but never
actually talked about the actual economy
we're living in and so if you actually
read the american economic review you'll
find us completely unreadable it's all
math it's all jargon and you would not
be alone if you're not exactly if you're
not subscribing to the American Economic
Review you're not alone they did a study
not long ago to ask how many people read
the average article in the american
economic review and the answer was two
and a half two and a half people reading
the typical article now I assume they're
not including the editor and the author
because then we'd be left with like a
half a guy running around reading arcs
so the fact that the mainstream is not
favorable toward the Austrian School of
Economics I I don't count as a demerit I
count that as a point in its favor I
don't see that the mainstream of the
profession has exactly been doing a
bang-up job recently well what I want to
talk about today is as follows I want to
explain first the precipitating factor
in what happened to us and no it's not
deregulation it's not the free market as
evil it's not all the nonsense you get
from CNBC or from the White House or
whatever all of that stuff is false
everybody who says the free market has
failed and so you know that the drones
who run the economy need more power is
just dead wrong so first what was the
precipitating factor secondly I want to
explain
I fiscal stimulus is a juvenile idea why
it only intensifies the problem likewise
for monetary stimulus and then proposed
what actually could be done to
accelerate the recovery and here i'm
going to make reference to an episode in
american history no one's ever heard of
a depression that was over in about a
year and a half because the government
did the exact opposite of what it's
doing right now so first first to the
Fed now the Fed has nothing in my
opinion whatsoever to do with the free
market the free market is the idea of
social cooperation bounded by private
property rights that we all engage in
voluntary transactions with each other
and we cannot trespass upon other
people's rights to life and property
that's all it is for all the boogeyman
definitions you've been given about the
wickedness of the free market that's all
it is there's no room in that set up for
a monopoly paper money producer that
violates the tenets of the free market
which opposes monopolies and the free
market would never produce a paper money
system like we have now where the money
is just paper it's not redeemable into
anything the system we have now has
never been created voluntarily through
the free market never no such thing it
has always been introduced through
government and through threats of
violence and and with the use of the
police to suppress alternatives it has
never spontaneously emerged so the Fed
therefore is going to be the target of
my remarks now I am of the opinion the
free market more or less works in every
situation and so I don't make an
exception to say that yeah the free
market works however when it comes to
money and interest rates there we need a
Soviet commissar engaging in a central
plan I don't see it seems like an
inconsistency I don't see any need to to
concede this and yet the chairman of the
Federal Reserve System from the late 80s
up till just a few years ago Alan
Greenspan was treated like a god among
men in our financial press and in
popular culture and television he was
called the maestro
the new york times in its typical
toadying totalitarian fashion referred
to greenspan as the infallible maestro
of our financial system bob woodward the
reporter for The Washington Post you
know supposedly the big
anti-establishment reporter right Bob
Woodward said that in The Wizard of Oz
and I see right away we're off to a
creepy start he says in The Wizard of Oz
when the man behind the curtain is
revealed we are disappointed but in
Greenspan we find comfort just creepy
right totally creepy I mean this is
beneath the dignity of a free people for
heaven's sake or my favorite example is
from the New Republic magazine which I
hope none of you waste your time reading
but the New Republic had a journalist
who had a little bit of a problem in the
1990s he used to just make up his
stories and just make them up and other
journalist would be wondering man why
didn't I get that story well cuz it came
out of this guy's brain it didn't
actually occur and one of the stories
that this guy wrote Stephen glass was
about Alan Greenspan and he told the
story that a group of Wall Street
executives had built a little shrine to
Greenspan with his image and some
flowers and candles and they would meet
there and meditate in front of it now
what's more amazing than that somebody
would invent a story like that is that
nobody noticed that was a phony story
people thought yeah that seems like a
reasonable thing somebody might do sure
something's wrong here this doesn't make
sense in a free society so I want to
puncture some of this bizarre aura that
surrounds both this man in particular
and the Federal Reserve he headed in
general now let's talk about a Nobel
Prize winner in economics who actually
deserved the prize unlike certain people
whose names we won't mention until later
today and that's fa hayek now Hayek won
the Nobel Prize for showing that central
banks like the Fed monopoly central
banks created by government and that
would be absolutely nothing without the
government granted monopoly privileges
they have destabilized the economy
forget all this mythology about what
wonderful stabilizing agents they are to
the contrary since we've had the Fed
when you compare the number of panics
and crises we've had it has doubled
since that time so don't give me the
it's a wonderful stabilizer that's a
whole lot of propaganda Hayek it's
significant that he wins a Nobel Prize
because Hayek is saying the exact
opposite of what the Nobel Committee
would want to hear they don't want to
hear that the whole central banking
thing is a big racket the destabilizes
rather than stabilize the economy so
it's very significant he wins at all
because he's saying the exact opposite
of what they would like to hear now
anybody can understand haix argument
well again with the exception of certain
recent Nobel Prize winners but anybody
in this room anybody watching a
television anybody can understand this
and if you really want to understand
what happened to the economy and why it
is completely even laughably bogus to
blame this on the free market I suggest
just just this two minutes you'll find
hey wait a minute this makes a lot of
sense in fact i'm happy to say i spoke
at the university of colorado at boulder
a few months ago and i didn't realize it
dumb me i didn't know until I got there
what boulders reputation was that you
know they're kind of on the political
left I didn't know that you know they
invited me to speak so I'm going and the
room was full I was happy to see on a
Friday night so I mean I don't care what
your political outlook is if you're
coming to an economics lecture on a
Friday night you get a pass from me so
these people were there and a lot of
them were Obama supporters and I thought
I'm not getting out of here alive but as
it turns out afterward they thought you
know hey you made a good present I got
an email later about this you got made a
good presentation you made us think you
know we don't we don't see what the
argument against what you're saying is I
did a show with a left-wing host in
advance of an appearance in West
Virginia Howard Monroe had ten minutes
to explain Hayek's theories does not me
it's not like I'm some genius I'm just
explaining Hayek's theory so in 10
minutes he said wow he said you know I
was expecting to hate you instead I you
know you make a good case and then
finally the guy who reads the audio book
whose of meltdown
and this guy's got the greatest reading
voice you can imagine you know it's like
he's like that guy from the movies have
just died you know in a world he's that
kind of voice he's an Obama supporter
too and he said when he got meltdown he
thought all here we go another bit of
right-wing propaganda about the free
market and he wrote to me and said I
have to admit you make a strong case so
it is nice once in a while that even
though we have disagreements with people
we can be civil and we can listen to
what we're saying you know isn't isn't
this a wonderful break from from the
what usually takes place well anyway
here's Hayek's argument very sperry
simply Hayek wants to know why is it the
economy moves like this how come we're
all doing great then everybody's in the
toilet and then great then up and down
why is this happening I mean this is you
know kind of an interesting question
isn't it why is this happening why is
there what the Economist lionel robbins
called a cluster of error where all of a
sudden people who had been great
forecasters of consumer demand turned
out to be terrible at it all at the same
time in the same direction like why
would this happen its demands
explanation the market weeds out people
who stink at anticipating consumer
demand those people make losses and or
go out of business and people who are
good at it expand and get more control
over capital so at any one time the
market is in fact promoting people who
are the best at doing this so why are
these people selected by the market for
they're forecasting ability why are they
all so bad at the same time good
question very rarely do you get an
answer to this question other than a
psychological one that oh well you know
there were animal spirits that sometimes
make them want to invest a lot and then
it turns around they don't want to
invest so much and whatever I mean what
a totally anti-intellectual unsatisfying
explanation this is Hayek says no there
are real factors that account for why
this occurs and now Hayek focuses on
interest rates and if you're inclined to
say okay interest rates is no way this
is too complicated whatever i'm telling
you interest rates are so important and
you're going to have you have a dream
tonight about a giant interest rate
symbol chasing you around cuz you
realize significance of this what Hayek
is saying is that you know interest
rates are not just arbitrary numbers you
can't just change them and expect
nothing to happen I mean we would all
like to have low interest rates in the
same way that we would all like to have
milk
sell for five cents a gallon but we only
want that if it occurs spontaneously if
the government makes Milk five cents a
gallon that doesn't mean we're all going
to get cheap milk means we're all going
to get no milk so we can't just simply
say anything that seems good for me as a
consumer must be good and super and
let's have the government just force it
well you might as well ask the
government to abolish the law of gravity
because that's in effect what you're
trying to do interest rates mean
something they are where they are for a
reason and if you interfere with them so
notice interfering in the free market if
you interfere with them you're going to
lead to massive dis coordination because
what does the interest rate do what
function what role does it play it
coordinates production across time which
is a fancy way of saying that when
people are willing to postpone their
purchases into the future well that's a
time when it makes sense for businesses
to engage in long-term projects that
will bear fruit only in the relatively
distant future whereas if people want to
consume right now this is not a time to
deploy resources on product development
for new products so the interest rate
coordinates demands of consumers for
goods now versus goods in the future and
secondly and this is really just the
other side of the same coin the interest
rate makes sure there are enough
resources actual physical resources
available in the economy to complete all
the relatively long term projects that
businesses engage in well when we save
more when you and I save more and we
restrict our consumption temporarily
this lowers the interest rate we put our
money in the banks this this pushes
interest rates lower the banks have more
to lend so to take a little shortcut
here the price of lending and effect
goes down just common sense well when we
do that that indicates number one we're
postponing our desire to consume into
the future and number two because we're
postponing our desire to consume we are
also releasing resources into the
economy for use by these longer-term
projects because if we're not going to
be producing as many a media consumer
goods well then some of the factors of
production that go into producing
consumer goods are now released and made
available
longer-term projects like research and
development or manufacturing or mining
expanding mining capacity now the reason
that low interest rates encourage
long-term investment should be obvious
the longer term your investment is the
more interest matters if I've got to
make a 10-year start a 10-year project
at fifteen percent interest well it
might just not even be worth my while
but if the interest rate comes down to
eight percent it might be profitable for
me to do it so the longer term the
investment is the more it's going to be
artificially stimulated if interest
rates are interfere with if interest
rates come down naturally because
there's more saving available well then
it does make sense for a long-term
investment to get started the resources
are available to do it people are
willing to wait the time it takes for
these projects immature so the interest
rate plays this crucial coordinating
function it's not it's not the case that
you can create a utopia by forcing
interest rates down artificially and
that all of a sudden you know it'll be
all just sunshine kittens everywhere
that is not the case the interest rate
is a genuine constraint that is there to
limit our ambitions to make clear to us
we cannot do everything simultaneously
we cannot begin every conceivable
production project at the same time it
limits this so high exploit is this
let's suppose interest rates come down
naturally well as we've seen we have
coordination because we have long-term
investments starting at a time when
people have deferred consumption and
released resources for use in
longer-term projects or we might call
higher order stages of production but
let's say you have a central bank like
the Fed that has various means to push
interest rates lower artificially well
what's the difference here well here we
have the same effect which is that more
long-term projects are undertaken but
notice the difference in this case
people haven't stopped consuming or
restricted their consumption they're
consuming just as much as before if
anything they're consuming even more
thanks to the low interest rates
discouraging them from saving so now
people are going to be consuming more
and not releasing resources so now these
long-term projects it's going to turn
out they're not all going to be
profitable because literally there
aren't enough resources to complete them
because the resources that are supposed
to be released from consumer goods
production into the production of these
more distant things haven't been
released so there isn't enough to go
around so the prices of these factors
are going to go up and that's going to
seriously compromise the profitability
of these new projects so that in a
nutshell is what Hayek is saying is that
you you sure you have a boom temporarily
people are building things but what good
is a boom if they're building things
they can't ever finish their building
things that don't correspond to what
consumers want that's what Hayek's
argument is if you interfere with the
structure of interest rates as the
market sets them the result is massive
error on the part of investors
businessmen and consumers alike this is
the source of the cluster of error now
Ludwig von Mises was the great Austrian
economist of the 20th century died in
1973 let me just point out that Mises
had to flee Nazi controlled Europe which
where he'd been teaching in Europe
teaching in Switzerland for a while and
he had to flee eventually but not only
because he was Jewish but also because
what he was teaching was not exactly in
conformity with the Nazi economic
program Mises was talking about the
international division of labor and how
the market is the best example of human
cooperation across borders and what a
wondrous thing it is that somehow we can
take resources from all over the place
and without any central direction we can
create wealth and what amazing wonderful
thing this is well you know that it's
not exactly what the autarky Nazi Party
wants to hear so they destroyed his
papers in his library he fled to the
United States where he arrived in 1940
in his late 50s almost empty handed not
speaking a word of English and with no
paid university position at a time when
every semi-competent every boob every
Marxist could find some employment
there's meeses one of the great economic
geniuses of all time and yet he went on
to be as productive if not more
productive than ever his great treatise
human action 1949 is a fantastic
bestseller even though it's 900 pages
Mises was an extraordinary genius whose
work is now
being studied and remembered at a time
when all those nobodies who were getting
hired and welcomed over him have long
since been forgotten well meeses after
after whom the institute i work for the
ludwig von mises institute is named in
human action gives a great analogy for
what's happening in the economy when in
fact you're playing havoc with interest
rates he says let's imagine the entire
economy as being a master builder
building a house and he's got a supply
of bricks that he thinks is larger than
it actually is and let's for the sake of
argument say these are all the bricks in
the whole economy well it's better for
him to discover this error earlier
rather than later because if he
discovers it earlier well he's only
squandered so many of them and he's only
wasted so much of his time but if he
discovers his error as he's putting on
the last brick well this is a disaster
he's wasted an awful lot more labour
time this this house part of it may have
to be demolished at this point if not
the whole thing whereas if he discovers
the error sooner well he can go back to
his blueprint he can cross things off
change things around make the best of
the situation but notice what would not
help him notice what would not help this
masterbuilder if we simply got him drunk
and said hey you know keep on building
well yeah then hey look he'll be happy
it'll look like an economic boom right
he's working right he's building this is
an economic boom right well is the house
anymore unbuildable unfinish abul than
it was before any less than it was
before of course not he still can't
finish it but now he's going to be
misled into continuing even longer well
that's what happens to the economy every
time people say the cure for low
interest rate problems is even lower
interest rates because in effect you're
saying to the economy sure you've
started off on investment projects that
can't possibly be completed the physical
resources don't exist to finish them
keep doing that how about start some
more that's what you're doing when you
say we need more more credit pumped into
the economy no we don't we need the
opposite we need the exact opposite of
that and what Mises example also shows
and I know this is easy to take out of
context and hostile people can interpret
it the wrong way but I'm speaking to
people of good will not not not hacks
and propagandists when I say that
the recession period the recession phase
as painful as it can be is actually when
we are restored to health because look
at the master builder example the
recession period is when his error comes
to light he says wait a minute I'm
engaged in an unsustainable project here
I either have to go back and scale back
my expectations or abandon this project
and move into something else that's a
good thing because in fact the bad part
was the boom when he was allocating
resources wrongly when he was
squandering them on projects the economy
doesn't have the resources to finish
that was bad that impoverishes us
because a lot of these resources cannot
be recovered and so we are that much the
poorer so the recession is when we say
all right wait a minute we've done a lot
of stupid things we shouldn't have done
and now we need to let the market price
system sort out what's profitable what
sound what's a bubble project what needs
to be abandoned and we'll just clean all
this out and start again on a firm
foundation that's what the recession
accomplishes and it can be short and
Swift if the government doesn't
interfere in it now we've just lived
through the classic example of what
happens when you have an economic
downturn and the authorities try to
inflate their way out of it create more
money pump it into the banking system
push interest rates down because
remember the dot-com boom of the love
the late 1990s where you had these
insane companies where you know they had
no customers nobody barely knew what
they were making if anything and yet
people were thinking they were going to
get rich investing in these companies a
crazy crazy sort of boom that eventually
went bust around 2000 well going into
2001 Alan Greenspan decided you know I'm
sick of this whole economic downturn
thing it's time to laugh again to quote
Homer Simpson we need to we need to pump
money into this economy and get interest
rates down and that will stimulate
things again well in fact he did that we
had 11 rate cuts in 2001 and this is
when he really started being called the
maestro because wow this man this mighty
overlord before whom we are not worthy
to stand in whose presence we must waive
incense
somehow held off an economic collapse
amazing what an extraordinary man this
is well here's what the extraordinary
man actually did in 2001 we had the
first recession on record we've ever had
in which housing starts didn't decline
so that's because Greenspan wouldn't let
the economy clear everything out all the
bad investments stupid production
decisions clear them out so instead
people drew the conclusion Wow we've had
a recession and yet housings still
robust so I guess that means housing
never goes down it's the best investment
you can make and all these myths get
started because Greenspan instead of
saying to people we've got to abandon a
lot of what we've been doing he says I
don't know full steam ahead keep on
doing what you've been doing so now the
crash we have now is all the worse
because in the interim we've been
persisting in these incorrect flows of
spending and production it's all the
worse because instead of being corrected
we were affirmed and so that is what
Greenspan has done and now recently we
had Greenspan all tears and pity on
television saying to us that you know
this crisis just goes to show that there
is a flaw in the free market that he had
never noticed before now of course it
means a lot when a guy like this people
falsely believe is a free market guy
because of his ein ran days 40 years ago
he's still a free market guy today and
people say well you know hey if even
Greenspan says there's a flaw who are
you you mere mortals who are you to
dispute what Greenspan says well I would
just simply say to Greenspan not that
he's listening he's off making 150
thousand dollars a speech pretty good
racket he's got going but I would say to
Alan Greenspan but we have found the
flaw and it is you
now without the Fed how could you have a
housing bubble now a lot of people have
tried to say these bubbles and what by
bubble I just mean that prices that are
unsustainably high they can't possibly
stay that I and I realize this is a
sensitive subject here in Las Vegas but
there's there's no getting around it
right we have to talk about this there
are some people who say this is just a
psychological phenomenon you know people
just become insanely attached to a
particular kind of investment or a
particular asset class and I don't mean
to discount psychological explanations I
do think that once a bubble gets going
it feeds on itself but I think the the
cause and effect and the the order is
sometimes mixed up because if it had
just been psychology well the market
would have put a damper on that simply
because where would you have gotten the
credit to keep investing in housing
because if there is if there is unusual
activity in some sector prices go up and
if you had a free market in banking
interest rates would go up to say hey
we're running out of stuff to lend you
but you don't actually need three houses
maybe you should rethink this but when
you have a Soviet commissar running
money and interest rates the big free
marketeer is the Soviet commissar
running money and interest rates then he
can create all this new money pump it in
keep interest rates low and keep this
artificial phony thing going so this is
this was always Mises argument and even
anna schwartz who's not an Austrian but
a Chicago School economist said that
anytime you have an asset bubble there's
always some kind of artificial credit
inflating it that's what that's what
doesn't because there's no way you'd be
able to afford the constantly increasing
price unless there was some consistent
spigot of credit being pumped into the
economy so it's not fair to blame hgtv
for the housing bubble I mean that's you
know it's it's a crazy simultaneous
thing and it may have played some some
minor role but without the Fed pressing
the accelerator we wouldn't have had
this problem we should also point out
that the issue of lowering lending
standards is not altogether separable
from the issue of the Fed it's not just
the Community Reinvestment Act it's that
if the Fed pumps money into the economy
into the banking system
well under the incentive structure we
have right now the banks want to stay
loaned up to the absolute legal extent
possible so if they get suddenly more
money to lend out it's burning a hole in
their pockets who is going to be the
recipients who will be the recipients of
this money if not people they would have
rejected otherwise because for example
the example I given in meltdown is let's
suppose I've got a basketball team and
then as soon as I pick my players I'm
suddenly told by the way you get to pick
two more well logically where am I going
to pick those two more players from from
the pool of people i had just rejected
so naturally the standards are going to
go down that that's unavoidable and all
through this by the way we had something
that investors new informally as the
Greenspan put which everyone understood
to mean that Greenspan is not going to
let things unravel if things turn bad
for major market actors he'll intervene
and bail you out and this happened time
and time again so the and this is this
is not some theory that I came up with
you can you can google Greenspan put and
find out all about this and again I talk
about it meltdown but again I mean is
this where is the free market in this
I'd like to know I mean in what way
could this be the free market what in
fact happens when you have a central
bank and particularly since 1971 what
happens is it institutionalizes what we
call moral hazard now we all know moral
hazard is the phenomenon in which people
become riskier when they believe that
any losses they make will be spread out
among the public instead of born buy
them individually they get to keep the
profits but spread out the losses well
the Fed institutionalizes this problem
because why should major why should
financial firms worry so much about
their capital why should they worry so
much about the types of investments that
they're making when they can get
injections of fresh liquidity when they
when they need them so naturally there
is going to be more risk-taking more
recklessness then there would otherwise
be I don't see how this can be disputed
it is the nature of the system and so if
people say we need more regulation you
have got to be kidding me that that's
the explanation we didn't have enough
regulator you've got to be kidding me
the banking industry is probably the
most heavily regulated in the whole the
whole country and the regulator's
thought the
the security security zation model was
working just fine it was just peachy so
what is one bit and now we're being told
we need a systemic regulator and that's
going to be the Fed the Fed creates the
systemic risk in the first place and now
they're going to maybe this is
unbalanced this is like we're living in
an or well novel combined with a Kafka
novel it's just unbelievable I mean you
wake up as a giant bug and they throw
you in jail I mean it's a it's a bizarre
situation we're facing now I'll point
out by the way that one objection to
what I'm saying would be yeah you know
in the 19th century we had a lot of
booms and busts you can't blame that on
Alan Greenspan well okay that's true I
can't blame that on a person who hadn't
yet been born in an institution that
didn't exist but again I talked about
this in meltdown if you look at those
cases in the 19th century they're all
caused by the same thing so we've either
got national banks enjoying special
government monopoly privileges and
abettor and/or a banking system that is
consistently bailed out when it gets
into trouble so therefore it can create
more credit in the economy than there
exists actual saved resources to back it
if you look at the 1870s supposedly the
time of the long depression worse
depression ever well actually economic
historians now don't even believe there
was a long depression in the 1870s they
actually don't even believe this
occurred now the consensus now is that
there was a there was a recession in
eighteen seventy three but at the 1870s
along with the 1880s were among the most
robust decades in American history
according to every criterion you can
imagine account of economic historians
were misled into thinking this must have
been a depression simply because prices
declined on average by about three point
eight percent per year and we've all
been told that declining prices is just
like death like the worst possible thing
zombies are going to roam the earth or
something if you have declining prices
that's actually how I won't get into
deflation here I talked about that in
the book too but that's actually a way
people become rich and in the old days
before the Fed you used to be able to
save by just accumulating precious metal
coins back when precious metals
circulated as
they held their value or gained slightly
in value when they circulated as money
and so how do people save for the future
they just simply saved coins they didn't
have to go into the stock market and
become speculators whereas today because
of the Fed which has lowered the value
of the dollar by ninety-five percent
since it was created no one in his right
mind would save by piling up green
pieces of paper you'd be wiped out you'd
be ruined no one can do that so instead
we all have to become speculators and go
into the stock market or invest in you
know heaven knows what or go into debt
to buy a house because we're told that
the house will keep up with inflation
and yet you can get wiped out and ruined
by this and yet we're told that this is
all for the common man the Fed is there
to help the common man you've got to be
kidding me this is unbelievable again
that and it's just every time I hear the
left talk about questioning Authority
and here you have the most regressive
institution imaginable that rewards the
financial elite in society and
discombobulates the financial planning
of every normal person in the country
and you can you can say that's not worth
questioning or you're a crank to
question you're a crank not to question
it at this point
so there is something wrong with the
money our money is can be created at
will in any quantity with basically
normals no resources expended this money
is pumped into the banking system pushes
the rate of interest down and creates
this boom and bust cycle and then when
the bust comes the major players who get
caught out in the bust then go crying
they're all tears and sadness they all
go crying to the central bank the paper
money producer because they know that
there is no physical constraint on how
much money the paper money producer can
create so they go to the paper money
producer and say bail me out and they
usually get what they want now it seems
to me that this is not obviously the
best conceivable system now we're being
told that what needs to be done is we
need fiscal stimulus oh boy this is this
one's rich we need fiscals that we got
we got to spend about eight hundred
billion dollars and blow it on
money-losing projects how do I know
their money losing projects if they
weren't the private sector would already
be engaged in them and secondly when the
heck has Barney Frank ever directed
money to something that made any sense
whatsoever so just sort of a priori you
know it's a money-losing project and by
the way I don't excuse Republicans who
will say that the problem with the
stimulus was that we didn't blow the 800
billion on the right things I mean this
is kind of again not not the sharpest
response you might you might make but
the fact is the government of course has
no profit and loss mechanism so it has
no way of knowing if it's doing well
doing destructively badly if it's
wasting resources if it's adding value
has no way of knowing has no feedback
mechanism and against its resources by
seizing them from the population kind of
kind of uncivilized so it has no way of
knowing how it's doing so these are all
going to basically lose money and this
is going to make us rich we're this is
what we're told it's going to make us
rich and and now Krugman Paul Krugman he
who shall not be named Paul Krugman says
we need more stimulus and notice the
problem is never that the first crazy
idea was a crazy idea it's that we
haven't done enough of the crazy idea
it is never lets reverse course and try
something else no no no we need to do
more and more we can do exactly what
Japan did we need to do exactly what
they did all through the 90s and they
continue to do and now they've just
contracted their economy has contracted
on an annualized at an annualized rate
of fifteen percent which you might
expect to hear for Haiti or something
but that's Japan after following the
advice of these geniuses who all try to
claim that oh no they didn't follow our
advice precisely they were off by
three-tenths of a percent look they did
everything that Keynesian 'he's wanted
them to do and they have this is what
they have to show for it is basically
basically a big ol 00 but in terms of
fiscal stimulus well first it diverts
resources writing because we're where
the resource is coming for these for
these projects it takes them away from
the private sector now you'll sit now
the sophisticated Keynes ians will come
back with these resources are idle
they're not doing anything anyway so
it's okay if we yank them back into into
production well yeah let's say that
would be the case perhaps if you could
devise stimulus packages that would make
use only of precisely the resources that
are currently idle but of course they're
not doing that they're coming up with a
whole bunch of totally arbitrary
projects all of which are going to
involve diverting steel or diverting
labor from places where they are
currently employed so this idle resource
argument doesn't work on those grounds
secondly again the argument from idle
resources we need to spend money we the
government to borrow money and blow it
to get all the resources we have their
idle back into productive activity well
they never ask the question why are all
these resources idle in the first place
why do we have idle capacity in the
first place what what's going on here
and the Austrian explanation would be
that this is a remnant of the artificial
boom that we've we've had production in
areas that can't be sustained and so we
don't we don't want to stimulate these
back into into use or at least not at
current prices we need to see what the
market decides where they should be
deployed right now it's like for example
a restaurant owner in Vancouver who when
the Olympics come he thinks hey great
you know apparently
everybody loves my food he doesn't
realize that the reason everybody's
coming into his restaurant is you know
the Olympics are in town and and you
know there are a lot of spectators and
athletes coming in and they all have the
Olympic circles you know rings on their
t-shirts and this guy isn't quite
noticing this so he thinks suddenly
everybody just loves my food I knew this
was bound to happen so he builds a
second location and then the Olympics go
away and now his second location always
waiters and waitresses are standing
around there getting no tips there's
nobody in there well should we want to
stimulate his idle resources back into
activity know obviously that would
divert resources away from healthy areas
of the economy where the market needs to
be given a chance to redeploy them it
would be a total waste to do this
stimulus packages are like drinking red
bull instead of sleeping because if
you've had red bull before which I
haven't by the way I'm just like this
naturally this is without red bull but
if you if you have red bull you know
that what it's actually doing it doesn't
actually there is no perpetual motion
machine you drink red Bull he's just
keep going no it's that whatever part of
your body is not totally exhausted the
red bull will totally exhaust and then
it's not like hey you know no crash is
coming off that crash is coming well
likewise the fiscal stimulus in effect
it seeks out like the parasite that it
is the the profitable sliver of the
economy and sucks resources out of it
and therefore exhaust the economy still
further now monetary stimulus let's
print up more money and blow it well
again we've already seen why that just
intensifies the problem that just puts
it off for a few more years and makes it
more intense when it actually gets here
so what we need in fact is the opposite
of this and interestingly enough in
American history we have an episode in
which that's exactly what was done and
that's 19 22 19 21 now some of you have
heard me talk about this over and over
again and I have a YouTube on this very
topic it's called why you've never heard
of the Great Depression of 1920 and it's
got like thirty three thousand views
this amazes me that people at this point
are so desperate to figure out what's
going on they'll sit in front of their
computers and like watch TV for 45
minutes about the Great Depression of
1920 that's wonderful p
listening that's wonderful well what
happened in nineteen twenty what we had
a depression that in which we had
double-digit unemployment we had
unemployment skyrocket from about four
to twelve percent we had production drop
off dramatically and what was done what
was done well between 1920 in 1922 the
federal government budget was cut in
half so instead of the fiscal stimulus
so-called we had the opposite of that I
mean today we're being told the worst
thing you can do is cut government
spending during a depression because
that'll cut into aggregate demand all
the simplistic nonsense that you can't
ever do that it's important for all the
congressmen to get their offices
renovated this is you know this is just
for the good of the country you
understand has nothing to do with what
we want I've got eight minutes oh how
much have I got okay okay because I
according to my watch it's only it's
only two we started 11 35 and 12 20 okay
all right well I'll try and finish in a
couple minutes well in any event in
1920-21 they did the opposite of this
the Fed basically stayed out and by the
mid mid nineteen twenty-one the crisis
was basically over so they did the exact
opposite of it and you never hear about
this episode ever and I talked about
this in that little YouTube I looked up
how economic historians dealt with that
episode here's the opposite of stimulus
it works fantastically I'm not kidding
there are books where there is one there
one or two sentences about this whole
episode there wasn't even a Wikipedia
entry on this until this year and
wikipedia has entries on you know like
the drummer for journey in the 1980s and
what his second wife did for a living I
mean there's nothing about this
whatsoever so given that apparently I'm
a lower on time than I realized I'll
simply say that the people we're told to
look to for advice the people we're told
to listen to the so-called experts have
no idea what they're talking about in
2001 Paul Krugman who writes for The New
York Times said that what we need more
than anything are low interest rates to
spur housing well that should pretty
much finish it for Paul Krugman but you
know working for the New York Times
means never having to say you're sorry
when you're wrong because you're always
wrong or you wouldn't be working for the
new york times but
we have not been listening to people who
actually know what they're talking about
who are the economist's of the Austrian
school we've been neglecting them
because they refuse to lick the
establishments boots but that is a
virtue not a demerit it is about time we
started listening to them I urge you to
check out meltdown visit me at Tom Woods
calm where I have a lot of articles
going after these people but ladies and
gentlemen we've been listening to the
quacks long enough let's try to make
some progress for a change and listen to
people who have some clue what they're
talking about thank you very